two different hoses are being used to
fill a fish pond used together the two
hoses take 12 minutes to fill the pond
if used alone one hose is able to fill
the pond 10 minutes faster than the
other so 10
minutes faster than the other hose how
long does each hose take to fill the
pond by itself so let's think about each
of the hoses we have a faster hose
we have a faster hose and then we have a
slower hose
and let's say that the faster hose fills
the pond let's say it takes him
him f
minutes
f minutes per pond
f minutes per pond
now how long is it going to take the
slower hose well the faster hose takes
it in does it in 10 minutes less it's 10
minutes faster so the slower hose is
going to take 10 minutes more so the
slower hose is going to take
f plus 10
minutes
minutes per
per fish pond or per pond now this is in
minutes per pond but if we want to be
able to add rates together we should
really think about it in terms of ponds
per minute so let's rewrite each of
these statements as ponds per minute you
could write this as f minutes per one
pond or f over 10 f plus 10 minutes per
one pond and if you just take the
inverse of each of these statements
these ratios are equivalent to saying
one
pond
one pond
per f
minutes so it's really not saying
anything else i'm just inverting the
ratio or you could think of it as one
over f pawns per minute
one over f pawns per minute same logic
right here
we could we could essentially rewrite
this ratio as one over
f plus ten
pounds
pounds per minute so now we have the
rate of the faster hose we have the rate
of the slower hose how many pounds per
minute for the faster hose how many
pounds per minute for the slower hose if
we add these two rates we'll know the
pawns per minute when they're acting
together
so if we have one over f
pawns per minute plus
one over f plus ten pounds per minute
this is the faster hose is the slower
hose this will tell us how many pounds
per minute they can do together now we
know that information they say the two
hoses the two hoses take 12 minutes
the two hoses take 12 minutes let me
write that over here so combined
the combined
take 12
minutes
per pond
12 minutes per pound so what is their
combined rate in terms of ponds per
minute so you could use this 12 minutes
for one pond you could take the inverse
of this or take the ratio in terms of
ponds per minute instead and you get 1
over 12
minutes sorry 1 over 12
pound ponds
ponds per minute
in 1 minute on combined they'll fill one
twelfth of a of a pond which makes
complete sense because it takes them 12
minutes to fill the whole thing so in
one minute they'll only do 1 12 of it so
this is their combined rate in ponds per
minute this is also their combined
combined rate in ponds per minute so
this is going to be equal to
1 over 12. and now we just have to solve
for f and then f plus 10 is going to be
what the how long it takes the slower
the slower hose so let's multiply let's
see what we could do we could multiply
both sides of this equation times f and
times f plus 10. so let's do that so i'm
going to multiply both sides of this
equation times f
and
f plus 10
times both sides of this equation so f
and f plus 10.
scroll down a little bit let me scroll
to the left so we have some real estate
so let's distribute this f times f plus
10. so if we multiply f times f plus 10
times one over f that f and that f will
cancel out and we're just going to be
left with an f plus 10. that's what when
you multiply that term times the f times
f plus 10. now when you multiply this
term when you multiply 1 over f plus 10
times f times f plus 10
this and this will cancel out and you're
just left with an f so you have plus f
is equal to and you have over 12.
actually well in the second let me
multiply all sides of this equation by
12. i'll do that next in a second so
let's
let's just say this is going to be equal
to 1 over 12 times
f squared
times f squared f times f is f squared
plus
10
f and now let's just multiply both sides
of this equation by 12. i could have
done it in the last step so that we
don't have any so that we don't have any
fractions here
so we don't have any fractions
and so the left hand side
we get 12 times f we get 12 f plus 120
plus 12 f the right hand side that and
that cancels out and you are left with f
squared plus 10 f
and now we have a quadratic we just have
to get into a form that we know how to
how to manipulate or deal with and
before that we can simplify it we have a
12f and a 12f so this becomes
24f plus 120
is equal to f squared plus 10 f
and then let's get all let's get all of
this stuff out of the left-hand side
look at all on the right-hand side so
from both sides of this equation let's
subtract 24f
and a negative 120 or minus 120. so you
have minus 24f
minus 120.
left-hand side just becomes 0. that was
the whole point
right-hand side is f squared
10 minus 24f is negative 14
f
minus
minus 120
now we could factor this let's see if
you do 20 times 6 yeah that looks like
it would work so 20 and
negative 20 and 6 when you take their
product give you negative 120 and
negative and negative 20 plus 6 is
negative 14.
so we could factor this right hand side
is 0 is equal to
f minus 20
times
f plus 6 when you multiply negative 20
times 6 you get negative 120 negative 20
plus 6 is negative 14 and the only way
that that's going to be equal to 0 is if
f minus 20
if f minus 20 is equal to 0 or
f plus 6 is equal to 0
add 20 to both sides of this equation
you get f is equal to 20 remember f is
how many minutes does it take for the
fast hose to fill the pond and then if
you take this one you subtract 6 from
both sides you get f is equal to
negative 6. now when we're talking about
how many minutes does it take for the
fast hose to fill the pond it doesn't
make any sense to say that it takes it
negative 6 minutes to fill the pond so
we can't use this answer we need a
positive answer so this is how many
minutes it takes the fast hose to fill
the pond f is equal to 20.
so the fog this right here the faster
hose takes 20 minutes
takes 20 minutes per pond so 20 i'll
write it here 20
minutes
per pond is a fast hose and the slower
hose it takes 10 minutes more it's f
plus 10. so it takes 30
minutes
per
pond and we're done i don't want to
confuse you with this stuff the faster
hose takes 20 minutes slower to hose
takes 30 minutes per pond if they were
to do it together it would take 12
minutes which is a little bit more than
half if you had two faster hoses it
would take 10 minutes but this guy's a
little bit slower so it's taking you a
little bit more than 10 minutes so it
makes sense it takes it takes you 12
minutes when they're working together